do you ever still have those moments
where you sit back and pinch yourself
and you say hi damn look at this career
of mine Molly I saw I had a dream when I
was at drama school of going to the
Royal National Theatre in London because
there being a lot as a kid and I was 28
and I was walking to work across the
water bridge to the Royal National
Theatre and I was starring in a guy over
there and I was like I haven't thought
beyond this point like I didn't have any
other girl like it that was it so I was
a 28 year old I was like everything has
been a bonus not just a bonus an
incredible magical journey that has
surprised me endlessly challenged me
I've loved it I loved it I was asking
Nicole this earlier because she's
getting the career achievement award
tonight hmm was there a defining moment
where she said you know what yeah I
think I can do this I think I do have a
career this was there a moment for you
where you thought yeah I'm good I don't
have to ever think about anything else
but this or you know you probably yeah
so I had a rule when I began I was 26
I've got my first job and I thought I'm
gonna give myself five years so I worked
I do well and after five years I thought
I was 31 I went and I just done the
first text man of it I might give it
another five years and after dad about
early thirties I was like I can't don't
worry about the five year thing but the
actual defining moment weirdly for me
was probably London like
I don't know if it's coming from
Australia its opposite side of the world
but soon as I went overseas and I was in
London and I was the Royal National
Theatre's search forever known as
directing and I was a big hit I was like
oh okay you don't can be okay you know
but I've never ever felt like I've
arrived ever never it does it's not like
that I've had some moments ago okay that
was great there's a famous story about
Olivier that backstage after one
performance he was sobbing and someone
said what smell he goes I can't do
better than that like that was perfect
and it I'm so sad because now I'll go
nowhere to go do you feel like you've
made a god I was gonna say do you feel
like you've had that moment some moments
of that I was really really happy with
for this a moments I'm sowing when I
could have done that better you know
watching that for me I was like what's
going on here I didn't see the other
nine takes which may not have been quite
as good you know so my experience if it
is different I just feel like I know I
just turned 50 but I I'm enjoying it
more than ever I feel like I'm just
beginning hey Nick Tommy I'm just taking
so much of your time
but she gave me some really key advice
early on cuz her and Deb my Deb would
like best friends Nicole they used to
fight together in LA when Nicole first
came to do Days of Thunder yeah Deb took
the call from Tom Cruise at the time the
first call yeah she's like okay she said
to me
director cute like choose the dirt in
film it's all about the director so
choose direct his different directors
you learn from every single one so many
different director so many different
genres always always you know dad and
she reads she's voracious reads porks
read scripts reading
but that's like what you said I was
saying about her you feel like at 50
you're hitting your stride I feel the
same with her I feel like she's like she
she here yeah no I she's always been
amazing but I know what you mean is it
from the decision making from the
producing into it as a as a confidence
it's like she's fully in integrity and
every single part of the decision-making
to the acting to the every part of it
and as humble as ever and confident and
I I sort of had a little window that I
feel a little the same I don't know what
it is I feel like I can't know what I
can do and I'm because of that willing
to take on bigger challenges
[Music]